well it was the longest apprenticeship
in history but King Charles III is here
as our Monarch he's going to take some
getting used to for everybody including
himself the new sovereign's already
faced criticism face past record of
asserting political opinions as well as
negative press this week about
redundancies at Clarence House he's also
being lambasted by the traditionally
sensitive corners of the internet for
his frustration with a leaking pen the
late Queen reacted in the same way asked
the trolls well probably not but should
King Charles face constant comparisons
with his mother is it time to embrace
King Charles for many years rather than
the woman that his mother was so joining
me now is King Charles's goddaughter
India Hicks plus Tony Esther is still
here India thank you so much uh for
joining me you are going to be at the
funeral you're also going to be at the
the committal of the Queen's body at the
very end of this extraordinary period of
mourning what are your feelings about
all this as someone who's obviously so
close to the family
I think that we're seeing
um in general an overwhelming uh
unification of people wanting to pay
their respects I think you've been
highlighting a few incidences here and
there I think we can all agree that our
kingdom our Commonwealth and the world
have come together to really thank an
extraordinary woman for the job she did
we now have to rely on an extraordinary
man which I think King Charles is to be
anything like as good a monarch as his
mother which would be an incredibly
tough challenge for anybody it doesn't
matter [ __ ] in my view she was the
greatest moment we've ever had
knowing him as you do is he up to this
job Princess Diana famously said in the
panoramans I think the top job will be
Beyond him but it looks to me from the
first few days it's not Beyond him at
all and he's rising to the challenge I
think what's interesting is he's so
completely different to his mother so
that it'll be a very a blank canvas on
which to paint his own picture which is
important
he will have a very strong Queen beside
him we know that Camilla is a very
strong woman look what she survived
already
um and I think together they have a very
good chance at doing an awful lot of
good and I think Charles has been vocal
in the past about what he uh feels uh
his passions
um he was prescient in his view on uh
ecology and the environment he did
things that none of us even began to
think about the word green
sustainability all of that didn't exist
but he can't do that now he can't but
why did you think he can keep to that
pledge I think that I'm an ambassador
for the princess trust um I've been
there for two years I've seen up close
and personal the change that that trust
has done it's been in place since 1976
who imagined that he would be able to do
that that is now a global Foundation the
astonishing amount of good it does is is
incredible and I think that he can step
away from that that will continue to be
its own motor its own course and he will
be able to now step into the shoes that
he has to have has he got to keep his
temper when his Pen's leaking
I think he is someone who is grieving he
is exhausted he has had to be on show
publicly every minute of the day for the
past five days it's an enormous thing to
undertake I think you're allowed to have
a bit of a temper tantrum on your pen
leaks I actually thought it was quite
endearing I've blown my stack over pens
before especially when they legal over
your hands Tony what do you think I mean
you wrote a great piece today in the sun
and it was about why the queen was the
biggest star of them all bigger than the
Beatles I've always felt that and he can
judge it by the sort of overall way that
even American Presidents behave when
they were around her but Charles has got
to start all over again now you know
he's been this Apprentice but now he is
King I think the reason uh hereditary
monarchy Works in this country is that
every Monarch earns the love of um of
our people and I think that the Queen to
me what's incredible is that she became
more important in her extreme old age
you know she was absolutely I can't
remember
um one word that a politician or
celebrity said during uh the covered
pandemic but I can remember we're told
Clarity those two four minute speeches
in the spring of 2020 yeah two four
minutes unless you know they're so brief
so brief so devastating you know just
those those words you know our streets
are not empty they're full of love uh
seared into the national Consciousness
um now my parents were not monarchists
my parents were not royalists um but the
the photograph where they look happiest
is when they were 20 years old going to
Buckingham Palace to meet King George VI
to collect my dad's distinguished
service medals they loved that King they
loved that shy kind Brave right and you
were saying about your mother that she's
on the verge of aquatic story possibly
unprecedented triple coronation well and
I love what you've just said now you
don't have to be a monarchist to find
pride in those moments they're leaders
these are leaders of our countries umly
is the faith and leaders and and so many
ways yes my mum uh went to King George
VI coronation at a little green cape
um and then she went to the queens and
if she has the stamina and the strength
to survive another year she could well
be into her third coronation I think
that's Guinness because if anybody's
ever done that that's part of me it's an
amazing she's an amazing person she's
the same she's the same breed as the
queen they are extraordinary women women
who have survived in a tough old man's
world think when the queen took that
Throne what she had to do who she had
put up you were a bridesmaid one year
Charles and Donna's I was what was it
like you remember it or not I remember
it very well
um it was it was amazing I tell you what
was amazing looking back now at this
grand old age 55. um was the crowds and
it's very rare that you see crowds who
aren't grieving or aren't angry or
aren't demonstrated these were crowds
who were Jubilee they were Jubilee they
were in Jubilation of the whole thing
and and they were excited and at that
stage it was a fairy tale wedding we all
believed the fairy tale was going to end
in the most wonderful way and and that
was really remarkable a lot of people
came out a lot of people came out yeah
amazing
one of the poll came out this week very
supportive of Charles his his popularity
surging as people think he'll be a good
King from 30 odd percent to 60 odd
percent in the space of three months so
immediate reaction for the public very
very positive 94 loved his first TV
address the only issue he has is age
profile of of support younger people
under 50 are supportive of of him
whereas older people are much more
supportive what does he do about the
youngin 73 you know my 10 year old
daughter looked at the TV and went he's
very old
she thinks I'm very old um what does he
do about the youth how does he connect
with them I think it just it's it's kind
of he just
had his role I think people develop a
love for the royal family when they
actually connect with them on a personal
level you can't keep comparing him to
the queen because you know he's not 26
Just Married with with kids right he's
he's a lot older um so he just needs to
settle into his role and the love will
come it just he has to curate his own
image and keep doing what he's been
doing so well that's why I also think if
you look at sort of um stratification as
well so it depends on sort of your
community background whether you come
from a family that already loves the
royal family sort of what your
Allegiance is to I suppose the
Commonwealth and to the United Kingdom
that all plays a role in who warms to
him final words well I was gonna have a
thought there which is I think that
actually Charles and Camilla it's a sort
of Fantastic Four they've got William
and Kate yes very powerful yeah William
and Kate do have the attention totally
agree with the younger I think we're in
good hands I think the the bloodstock is
good